I bet you're wondering why I'm in bed.
It's because today's Good in 5, we're tackling sleep.
(audience applauding)
(man snoring)
So I'm excited because I've got tips and tricks
that you can do in just five minutes
before you lay your head down for a good night's sleep.
First up is something to help you relax
and get you into that snoozy mood.
All right, check out this gadget.
I haven't tried this yet.
It's called the Renpho Eye Massager.
And it's a device that you wear on your eyes
for five minutes and it has massage modes,
including the sleep mode.
And it's supposed to reverse the effects of eye fatigue
to relieve stress and help you sleep well.
Two of our audience members, Anna and Brittany
are also wearing one too.
All right.
Let's see, oh, whoa.
Oh, whoa.
They're heated.
Anna?
Yep.
What do you think?
Oh, it's interesting.
(audience chuckling)
Brittany?
I can't see anything, but it's very nice.
I'm not gonna lie.
It's kinda hot and sexy.
I'm not kidding.
I'm not kidding relaxed, I'm getting totally stimulated.
(audience laughing)
Anna, Brittany, what's it doing for you guys?
I honestly don't know.
Well, after I made it awkward.
It's overwhelming a little bit.
What?
I love it.
It's like a warm cookie on your face.
(audience laughing)
Did you say warm cookie?
I should also mention I'm hungry.
Huh?
I've never felt a sensation like that.
I think I just discovered a new erogenous zone.
(audience laughing and applauding)
I'm excited.
I wanna bring in clinical psychologist, Dr. Shelby Harris,
who specializes in behavioral sleep medicine.
Hello.
Hi Drew.
(audience applauding)
Thanks for having me.
Have you ever tried that eye mask?
I have not tried that myself.
It looked like we had some
varied responses to it right here.
I mean, whoa.
They seemed really different.
Now you say that achieving good sleep
starts even before bedtime.
Enlighten me.
So I always think about sleep as like an on...
It's not an on off switch.
It's more like a dimmer switch.
So doing a wind down routine, ideally an hour.
But most of us don't have an hour.
So start with five minutes of relaxation
whatever you find is quieting.
Just do it for five minutes,
then move to 10 minutes and really try to set that stage.
And the other thing I also would argue is that
a good bedtime comes with a good morning time.
So if you're consistent with the morning wake up time
every day, you get bright light, you move,
you have a big glass of water.
That actually helps to set your bedtime
so you fall asleep a little bit better as well.
Now how about books?
'Cause I tend to like that for me is the dimmer switch.
I'll get off TV, I'll get off tech.
I'll kinda lie in bed and stare.
And then, I'll put my glasses on and read.
Is that still a stimulation
or is that okay of a transition?
It really varies on the person, honestly.
So reading I think is fantastic for a lot of people.
Depends, some people find reading
just too engrossing for them.
But for most people, find something that you enjoy
that passes the time and quiets your brain down.
But also be careful what you're reading on, right?
So are we reading on our little phone?
Or a tablet?
Oh no, never.
Book.
Like a lot of patient...
Good, I'm like a huge fan of go old school.
Okay, our next tip is someone to follow
that'll get you that great REM sleep.
I want you to check out the couple
who wants to help you relax.
Hayley and Grant's Sleep Granted ASMR YouTube channel.
Hayley and Grant post videos whispering bedtime stories
so that you can lull into relaxation and peace.
Dr. Shelby, why is everyone on the ASMR feeder?
So ASMR is a fancy word or it's a fancy letters
for autonomous sensory meridian response.
All that really means is that kind of tingly sensation
that you get down your spine?
Mhm.
Right?
So you can get it from videos like that.
Some people will get it from music.
Other people, like I notice sometimes
if my daughter's brushing my hair,
you get that just kind of pleasurable relaxation feeling
or a massage, anything like that.
So although there isn't a lot of research on it for sleep,
we do find that it activates parts of the brain
that promote hormones and neurotransmitters
that are relaxing, that induce sleep,
and that are pleasure inducing,
like oxytocin, dopamine, serotonin.
So it could, in theory, help for some people,
if you have the occasional bad night here and there.
Well finally, something good to do.
Dr. Shelby, you have a breathing exercise
that we can all do to quiet our mind.
So we're talking about that dimmer switch earlier?
What I always do myself, is I always just do
a quick three to five minute deep breathing exercise.
And I think, and I'm gonna teach it all to you.
And I think a lot of people, when they do deep breathing,
they're often breathing...
Ah, there you go.
I have it and I still forget to do it.
So when you're learning at the beginning,
a lot of people when they do deep breathing,
they breathe through their chest
which can make them feel a little bit more stressed.
So I have you put one hand on your chest
and one hand you're on your belly
and I encourage everyone to do that.
So you take a deep breath in
and you want this hand to move more
and this should stay still.
It's hard when you're standing.
But inhale.
Exhale.
And then you just say, "Relax".
Inhale.
Exhale.
Relax, one.
Inhale.
Exhale.
Relax, two.
And you count up to 10 and back down to one, very slowly.
It's harder to breathe fast when you're doing it this way.
It's easier when you're lying down, like I said.
Well, before we go, let's check in on Anna and Brittany.
Ladies, how do you feel?
(audience members chuckling)
I dunno.
I don't think I would use it, but I get it.
Right, like...
That is totally how I feel.
You summed it up perfectly.
Brittany?
I have the exact opposite feelings.
I absolutely love this thing.
It's like a warmth towel massage to your face.
It's very relaxing.
(upbeat music)